Johnathan's with me in West Palm Beach
Florida hi Jonathan welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show
hi there was a pleasure to talk to you
too what's up all right so we've got
quite the uphill battle to climb with
our debt my wife's a nurse and I'm a
pharmacist and we owe like three hundred
seventy thousand we've been on a budget
for the past year so we've been able to
pay like thirty thousand we found out in
February that we've got our second baby
on the way
so we're powering up cash and the baby's
due in October we're gonna get back your
paintings off and really the question is
what do you guys might we make about a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars why
have you only paid off thirty thousand
dollars that's lame I mean I know I we
need to dig deeper into the intra-party
oh that would be an understatement you
have three hundred thousand dollars in
debt and $180,000 income okay I think
you should put a hundred and ten
thousand dollars a year for three years
on your dad and be done and have
absolutely no freakin life when cry me a
river you're living on 70 grand I think
it's just too much extract yeah
the main question I don't think I can
help you until you're ready to get out
of debt I don't think I can help you
you're gonna have to get really angry
about this situation because dude you
are freaking broke and you're doing
almost nothing about it yeah how long I
should wait until I start to read set my
restart my 401k that will be
approximately three years after you have
no life for three years and get out of
debt okay that would be my prescription
I'm serious man you're gonna have to get
with it you are playing with this and it
is not moving
it's a your attempt as a joke so far and
you got babies coming and
he's gonna reach a point that this
180,000 our income which is about half
of its hers she's gonna reach a point
she won't do that anymore and you're
gonna still be sitting there with Sallie
Mae all loaded up in your spare bedroom
and you have got to address this monster
this elephant sitting in the middle of
your living room and it's making a mess
and you you got you got to get her out
of there man it's a big big big deal I
would be sitting I mean you're a young
dad two babies a young wife I mean you
should be so scared you can't breathe
and you're not yet I'm gonna try to get
you there and I'll walk with you when
you want some help but you're gonna have
to get like way more serious and pissed
off about this than you are right now
hope that helps you sir you used to keep
listening
I'll keep messing with you it's my job I
love you and I want you to win but right
now what you're doing sucks this is the
Dave Ramsey show